watch how easy it is to wipe out this dirty pan
I'm literally using a baby wipe and only one hand
cause I'm recording with the other hand
and look like nothing was ever cooked in there
and you know what I did cook in there
chicken thighs
greasy skin and bone in chicken thighs
and they came out like nothing
look at this Mac and cheese
it's bubbling hot
loaded with cheese
I cooked it on the stove and then moved it to finish in the oven
look how easy it slides out the
I'm not even using two hands
and nothing sticks at all
nothing like brand new
like straight out of the cabinet practically
they're super space shaving because the handle comes off
which I thought was weird
but it's super easy how it clicks on and clicks off
it is compatible with all of the pans
so you can take it off of one
put it on the other
and then for
especially if you have a house with little kids
you can just safely set the handle off to the side
so it's not like little hands are gonna grab it
and be in any danger while you're cooking
I that part is really amazing for me
the handle is really sturdy though
you can still carry the heavy hot pots over to the water to drain if you need to
or use them in any other way
also since it has these
this clippable handle
you can put things in the oven
and you don't need to worry about where your hot pad is
and no little hands can reach in there and accidentally grab it
you just use it to pull the item out of the oven
or to push it back in the oven
you clip it off
and again you just set it safely to the side
not only that
but because of the handle
they stack neatly and space saving inside of each other
this set is amazing
the link is here to buy one